accessibility
visibility breaking down the barriers
for people with disabilities
in media please welcome academy governor
and oscar winning actor
whoopi goldberg whoopi goldberg is a
black woman with shoulder-length black
dreadlocks
brown eyes and is wearing purple round
glasses and silver hoop earrings
she is wearing a very light lavender
colored top with white buttons and a
black necklace
with blue and white beads and she is
sitting in a white chair
against a textured background hey
i'm whoopi goldberg and i am proud to be
a governor of the academy of motion
picture arts and sciences
the actors branch you know 2020 marks
the
30th anniversary of the americans with
disabilities act
it's a civil rights law prohibiting
discrimination
against individuals with disabilities in
all life areas including jobs
schools transportation and public and
private places that are open to the
general public
it guarantees equal opportunity for all
individuals with disabilities
regardless of race color sex national
origin
age and religion one in five
americans have a disability making them
a part of america's
largest minority group but not all
disabilities
are immediately apparent
in this program we will hear from an
immensely talented and diverse group of
industry professionals
actors and managers directors sound
designers
vfx artists animators all who happen to
have a disability
so thank you to all our panelists and a
big thank you
to the rudiment family foundation for
the grant which makes this program
possible
i think you'll agree yes we can always
do better
but we hope these discussions will help
educate and highlight the importance
and advantages of hiring people with
disabilities
whether it be in front of the camera or
behind the scenes
please welcome our host oscar winning
actor marlee matlin
and interpreter jack jason marley matlin
is a white woman with below the shoulder
length blonde hair
and blue eyes she is wearing a solid
white top
gold hoop earrings and a gold necklace
she is sitting in a multicolored chair
in an office space in front of a large
blue and white painting
some photographs her oscar statuette and
white and yellow roses
while rarity in motion pictures
authentic disability representation can
be traced back to the silent era
films including you'd be surprised in
1926
the best years of our lives in 1946
children of a lesser god 1986 when i
walk
in 2013 the writer in 2017
the silent child in 2017 a quiet place
in 2018 give me liberty in 2019 and the
peanut butter falcon
in 2019 featured lived
disability experiences let's hear from
actor
danny woodburn and actor comedian
maysoon zayed
and talent manager aaron brown about
authentic representation
why it matters and how far we have come
authentic representation why it matters
and how far we have come
with actor danny woodburn actor and
comedian my son zaid
and talent manager aaron brown hi
everyone
i'm danny woodburn actor comedian
and activist i'm a white male
man with dwarfism um i am wearing a blue
shirt i had to look i'm wearing a blue
shirt uh blue suspenders i have a full
beard
and the hairline of a cruise ship
captain
before we get started it's my pleasure
to welcome amanda
grazian who will be our asl interpreter
for this discussion
i am a caucasian female with shoulder
length brown hair
blue eyes and a black suit jacket thank
you for being here
next we have my friend comedian actor
writer maisoon zayed
as a comedian mason has toured
extensively at home and abroad
she had the most viewed ted talk of 2014
and is the author of a best-selling
memoir find another dream
she appeared alongside adam sandler in
the movie one of my favorites you don't
mess with the zohan
and is a recurring character on general
hospital who i believe has not been
slapped in the face yet
uh thank you for that stellar
introduction
i want to describe myself to the
audience i look like the lost
kardashian i have cinnamon skin long
black hair
and i'm wearing a prince purple rain
calvin klein suit
with a black and blue sparkly shirt next
up we have talent manager aaron brown
aaron is partner at management 360 and
has guided the careers of critically
acclaimed artists such as academy award
winner
sebastian lelio of a fantastic woman
pablo lorraine of jackie bill johnson of
wreck-it ralph
and zootopia and kate shortland of black
widow
my name is erin brown i am a 46 year old
white woman with light brown hair i was
born with an
undiagnosed muscular myopathy
i'm wearing a blue and white pinstripe
shirt with a ruffled collar and a
bubblegum pink
cardigan behind me over my right
shoulder
is wallpaper with blue and pink
palm fronds and over my left shoulder is
a glass
wall with more palms i didn't get as
descriptive with my clothing as you can
but anyway welcome to you both um we
have a very interesting panel
uh the panel let's call it this
authentic representation why it matters
and how far we have come so the obvious
first question is
why does it matter and how far have we
come we
hear the hashtag all the time
representation matters but i want to
talk about
why it actually matters people with
disabilities are 20
at least maybe 25 of the population
but we're only two percent of the images
you see on tv
and 95 of those images are non-disabled
performers the message being sent out to
disabled kids
is you do not belong in this world
it is a very very dangerous message
it adds to the stigma against visible
disabilities
and invisible disabilities because we
actually have no idea how many people
with invisible disabilities grace our
screens because the stigma is so strong
that even celebrities feel you know fear
revealing that they're part of the
disability community
so one of the reasons i think it matters
is because
people with disabilities face enormous
amounts of bullying
of violence and of discrimination and i
believe
that positive images of disability in
both fiction
and non-fiction can help stop
the violence that we as a community face
my personal feeling is that
in the last five years i have felt sort
of an exponential shift
compared to the previous 20. i don't
know if you feel you guys feel the same
way that you're having
i feel like we're in so much trouble and
that's gotten so much worse so you are
as you said the voice of doom but i
i'm the goddess of darkness
of disability on screen is mostly white
men
so that's not really feeling very
representative to me
as a woman of color or someone you know
who works in the intersectionality of
the community
i think that the images that we are
seeing are still
to infantilized too much inspiration
porn
and i know i know that the stories are
not being told by
us i still feel like any time i enter
a room a studio or a set i'm the only
disabled person
it's daunting being the only disabled
person and i don't really feel like
we've made progress until big stars
finally say no to playing disabled on
screen
if they are not disabled in real life
once we have people saying no to that
then i'll think we've moved forward
aaron do you feel like
as a as a person that works with you
know uh with creative as a person who
essentially is is connecting to um
decision makers right writers producers
do you feel like there's a shift or how
do you feel about you know
where we are where we've come from i
guess i have to agree with
may soon i've never seen myself
on television and the the great surprise
for me was that i didn't realize
that i had never seen myself on tv until
a couple of years ago
when a colleague took me to the premiere
of his clients
special which is a wonderful
series written and created and starring
ryan o'connell
and it was the first time that i saw
a disabled person just existing in their
life and doing normal things like
dating and having fights with their
friends and squabbles with their parents
and i'm not young
i'm not a man and i'm not gay
but that was the first time i felt like
i had even seen a shred of something
that i related to
do you feel like you have any influence
over the talent that you represent
like just your your mere presence or
them
connecting to you on a different level
is a writer ever come to you and said
look i'm writing the story
you know what do you think of this they
ask you opinion if there's not other
disabled writers in the room
would they ask your opinion uh as maybe
their only
resource no they haven't i do
feel that i have a lot of influence and
i take
very seriously the responsibility um
my contribution to the culture that i
help create through the work of my
clients but
the stigma of disability is so
strong and so shameful that there has
been
a lack of discourse about
it even between me and my own
clients because as i do you know gently
try to
explore that and and suggest when people
are talking about
lgbtq or by characters i'll say what
about someone in a wheelchair
but you know it's a fine line i don't
want anyone to think that i'm servicing
a particular agenda or one of my own
right well you know it for me
uh you know growing up i know you you
said you didn't really see yourself
represented
and the times that i did see myself i
grew up in the
70s predominantly it's where i think the
formative years occurred for me and and
seeing
somebody like michael dunn it was a
little person actor billy barty on
screen
a lot of times it came with uh pathos
you know it filled in a lot of the the
blanks for the tropes around disability
you know
uh this the sad sad little man or
the devious little man or something like
that i don't know that there were
very many positives i appreciated their
performances i appreciated what they
were able to do
as actors but a lot of times the the
storylines were the same
i connected more to somebody like sydney
poitier who
for me was like a powerful influence on
you know in in my sense what it meant to
be accepted as a man
i think that really is like a big
reality that
still remains prevalent is that like
disabled people only get three story
lines
right you can't love me because i'm
disabled
heal me or kill me i grew up seeing a
lot of disabled stories where
families were better off when the
disabled person died
or i saw a lot of disabled people being
healed
and i i always talk about this one image
that stuck with me forever
was there was a blind character on
little house on the prairie
and he got caught in an explosion and he
got his vision back
and like i'm really glad i didn't blow
myself up as a kid
trying to heal myself like these things
are really dangerous and we're just like
inundated with these images that we
either have to be
you know charity cases where you get a
blanket
if you give us money or kill us and your
life will be better
and i think we're still kind of living
in those three stories
which is why i really do enjoy working
with both aaron and danny
because i think we really are fighting
for those mainstream images like danny
said
he was influenced by sydney portia i was
influenced by dolly parton and like the
fact that she's not disabled never
occurred to me it was like
that was the kind of entertainer i
wanted to be
and i pursued it and i managed to
navigate that world by going through
comedy because i did not see people who
looked like me
on television except in the world of
comedy
because comedy is kind of like the home
of misfits
right my comedy career was basically i
was told from
early on you just do short jokes it was
never about addressing
sort of the way society has been looking
at me and how it's been wrong but how i
should look at myself
as wrong so i in my comedy i sort of
flipped that
that's the challenge that we have to
to dismantle is that the content that's
been made
suggests that we are the problem and
when you internalize that
from a very young age why would i bring
it up
to to people you know whether it's my
clients or otherwise because
i i'm the problem in the world the world
isn't the problem it's me
we've tried everything we've tried
shaming actors into not playing disabled
if they're not disabled we've tried
showing our buying power
we've shown that we have the talent
we've shown that any project we do
ends up being successful it's not
working i've been doing it for 20 years
and disabled people are still being
shunned
we're not allowed to tell our stories
and we're simply not
included even close to the level that we
need to be
so i wish i had some like positive story
about
never giving up and creating your own
stuff but
i i don't know i think it has to be
something where
the unions demand equal representation
and that if projects
aren't inclusive and aren't accessible
then they don't get
the status that they need to go forward
it has to be like
legislated for it to actually happen i
don't think just
trying to convince hollywood to give us
a chance has worked in the past 50 years
and
it doesn't look like it's going to
change unless it's forced to
we still have so much so much um such an
uphill battle because you know for the
longest time as you both know i'm sure
we have not been included in the
diversity discussion
and then when we do make a little
headway uh for example
what what the academy put out recently
with regard to
you know nomination requirements there's
tremendous pushback from
supposed progressives who see this as
you know a slight to the ark
and they make these comments without a
full understanding of the scope
of what has gone on for for years and
years and years
and what continues to go on unchanged
and
like well you know art is supposed to be
all inclusive is it not
and they don't have that understanding
of that part of the conversation
i think there's so many layers here and
i think that a raised
awareness in this moment of cultural
reckoning is really imperative and
pointing out include disability in the
conversation
when there are conversations about lgbtq
and biopoc that disability is a category
that is automatically discussed so it
becomes normalized and then i think that
there will have to be something
that's a big disrupter i agree
with mason i don't know if it's if it's
legislation or
certain companies decide that
they want to support and they want to
get
behind a movement that says not only
this is the right
thing to do but it's good business and a
hazmat
really positive cultural ramifications
and
and you know it's opportunity for an
intersectional
movement because disability affects
every
group and anyone at any moment can
become
disabled so it's in everyone's best
interest for the world to be
accommodating
adam sandler told me the best thing ever
because
i know it's really hard for disabled
people to ask for accommodations you
finally make it through the door
and the last thing you want to do is be
a burden
delay any shooting and i was having
trouble getting in and out of my trailer
so i was basically jumping into a pa's
arms
and adam sandler saw me and he was like
what is happening
make her trailer accessible and i said
to him
you know i really didn't want to be high
maintenance and he said
look around we were in hollywood
i was on a set with mariah carey i was
not the person who was high maintenance
so we have to get rid of that fear of
asking
but also understand that we will be met
with resistance
so even though it's not our job it's
good when you're asking for
accommodations
to know what the solution is
even better it shouldn't be your
responsibility to ask
for accommodations it should be part
of the contract and yeah part of the
line producer and a part of
the production where they ask you what
do
you need to do your job right and it's
not it's just not
i think it's also has to do with how
forget the stigma around disability
there's a stigma around actors right
i think we need a disabled disney
princess so we do have one disney
disability icon
nemo he's got the bum fin and there's
you know a belief that lilo and stitch
is also a disabled story i think it'd be
really helpful to have a disabled
princess i want to end on a positive
note because i was like so doom and
gloom
a lot of disabled people are putting out
a lot of fantastic work it's amazing
like you know danny and i are producing
this show
and the number of new talent
applications we got
was astounding and the amount of just
pure talent in this community
that exists that is ready for their
close-up
is really inspiring i'm seeing disabled
people
in every area excelling we just need to
make sure they get the chance
there's not a lack of talented disabled
people in the world
it's just the lack of the ability to
showcase it
and i think too uh the people that we
get that have the talent
i think the powers that be have to
recognize they fought harder for their
education than anybody else and they
did all that they could to learn their
craft and be exceptional
and so i feel like that's you know we we
had to sort of
go that extra mile that that a
non-disabled person doesn't have to go
to get to that place of being accepted
as a viable talent
that i think should be something on the
minds of people in the
in the position of casting or producing
a project
that they go oh this this person really
has come a long way to get to this spot
where i'm interested in what they're
doing and it's an unfortunate reality
that we have to go that extra mile
but i think if they have a better
understanding that we've gone that extra
mile
then we'll be in a place where these
panels
are obsolete i don't want our panels to
be obsolete this is the most fun i've
had since the pandemics started
i think that one thing that would really
change everything
is if me and danny co-hosted the next
oscars
that would be the disability
representation that pushed
everyone to have equal disabled
representation on all their shows
i think that couldn't have said a better
idea
a year and a half to come up with it
really an
idea i wonder who we could talk to i
wonder
i think it's interesting to point out
that i think there have been 62
uh nominees for characters with
disability over the
oscars history there have been 27
winners of that category for best actors
or supporting actor actress but only two
had actual disability so what better way
to
shift the paradigm than to have may soon
and i host the show
i'll do your hair and makeup oh cool
awesome
you know how to do lost kardashian i'll
learn
and cruise ship captain you're gonna do
that inclusive captain
all right thank you both so much um
thank you so much for having us and
thanks to the academy
and now please welcome back marley
matlin
not only do inclusion writers call for
diversity in front of the camera
but they also strive for equity and
inclusivity
behind the scenes employers might be
hesitant to hire
industry professionals with disabilities
because of additional costs
but incorporating accessibility measures
open up employers to a pool of qualified
applicants
often overlooked in the past
filmmakers jenny gold jim lebrecht
and visual effects supervisor caitlin
yang
have created successful and accessible
businesses
for below the line professionals with
disabilities
let's hear from them about their work
behind the camera
why inclusion benefits us all
behind the camera why inclusion benefits
us all
with filmmakers jenny gold and jim
lebrecht and vfx supervisor
caitlin young hi i'm jenny gold
i have blonde hair and brown eyes
i'm wearing a red shirt with a pattern
and i'm sitting in a power wheelchair
in my home theater you might know me
best from the
film i produced and directed the
award-winning star-studded cinemability
the art of inclusion and now let me
introduce two good friends
and remarkable people first the talented
james labreck who has more than 35 years
of experience
as a film and theater sound designer and
mixer
he is also a founder of berkeley sound
artist
an audio post-production company and the
co-director and co-producer
with nicole newnham of the netflix
documentary
[ __ ] camp hey jim welcome
hi jenny great to be here i
am a older white guy with a
gray goatee and kind of brownish long
hair and i've got a blue patterned shirt
on
i am in my home office in oakland uh
there's a red wall behind me with some
posters on it
and that about sums me up now i have the
pleasure
of introducing visual effects supervisor
caitlin young
who is the founder of alpha studios
katelyn has more than 50 credits to her
name
including robot chicken grey's anatomy
and four weddings and a funeral thanks
for joining us caitlin
hey jenny hey jim thank you for having
me um
i am a asian american woman um i
am at my office with white walls behind
me with some posters
of our most recent work and as always
i'm surrounded by computers
and monitors thanks for joining us
caitlin and welcome everyone as we take
a look
behind the camera to discuss why
inclusion
benefits us all so let's discuss it
well i think that the more varied voices
and experiences that
come into a a team working on a film
the greater the possibility for bringing
out
nuance and stories that really paint a a
brighter picture
to what we're doing i think for me you
know right now in hollywood we are not
only
craving for ourselves to be seen but
we're really craving stories that we
haven't heard before
and i think one great you know treasure
trove of stories that we haven't heard
before
are from people who are underrepresented
especially
people with disabilities and i think it
makes for
great storytelling um it also makes
great business sense as well
right um we kind of make up one-fourth
of america which is kind of crazy if you
think about it everyone with
a physical or invisible disability and i
think it's just
you know good business sense you know
for us to be included
not only in front of the camera but also
behind the camera so we can support one
another
with the dollars that we're essentially
voting whenever we're going to support
a movie how can we help other
professionals make sure that when
they're hiring
that they look for qualified candidates
who might have disabilities
i think in terms of hiring you know as
we all know
the world is really not made for people
like us
if anything we're used to is we're using
to you know adapting
um our environment for it to work for us
and that
transitions into so many transferable
skills
you know especially in the filmmaking
community a lot of times you have to
think on your
you know on your toes and come up with
ideas and you know all you know all the
good stuff that we are
you know we've been essentially doing
our you know our whole lives
and i think for people with disabilities
we do have to work
way harder than others to get a seat at
the table
i would say that the entry into our
business
um not only just having a disability but
it comes down to
unpaid internships there are plenty of
people who economically cannot do that
and they are being filtered out and then
when we look at what qualifications
we're looking for
for people or how people kind of get
into our business
now we have to kind of steer away from
this idea of the entry level position of
somebody who
is a production assistant that can carry
14
cups of coffee onto the set
or that can work 20 hour days and in the
past i think it's been traditional that
we think that
if you're not willing to put in the long
long hours and stuff then you really
aren't dedicated um you know to working
and it's simply not true
jim i think you know you're hitting so
many great points there um i think one
of them is we've been
overlooked for so long for a lot of
qualifications that we've been doing you
know
um as we navigate not only our
professional lives but also you know
personal lives as well
i like to joke and say that you know we
we kind of show
up and we kind of do byoc bring our own
shares right and i think especially for
post-production
you're looking for talented people to
stand in front of a computer all day
problem solving and that is our strength
um you know it's it's interesting i've
come to realize that my disability is an
advantage for me
in my career choice as a director you
have to direct someone to do what you
want them to do
which is part of the skill that i use on
set with actors i'm getting them to do
what i want them to do
my way i grew up doing that and i think
that
a lot of people do look at it as a
negative but it can be a positive
a phrase i hear a lot is um i'm a very
precise communicator
and i say all the information up front
without you having to come back and ask
for clarifications
and i do this because you know once
again i have been doing this my entire
life
the ways that we're describing what we
need to see
and you know and the order that will be
most helpful for it to happen
that's again is one of our strengths
it's one of our expertise and i think
a lot of times precise communication
it equals less communication and it
saves more
money if you can get someone who has a
vision
and is very comfortable describing that
particular vision to entire team
like i do as a visual effects supervisor
right that's my job on the daily basis
that will benefit the post-production
team overall
so zoom is a big deal now everyone's
using it for meetings
and they're becoming more um comfortable
with the idea how do you think that is
affecting your meetings and your future
plans of continuing to work with it or
not
so it's interesting that you bring it up
one of the silver linings i have found
you know during covid and taking a lot
of meetings
via video conferencing on zoom or other
platforms
is i'm finding that video conferencing
is kind of
taking away the uncomfortableness that a
lot of people might have
if i were to take the same meeting and i
would go into their boardroom and i will
row in
my chair now i feel like zoom is kind of
putting us on
an equal playing field or getting closer
to at least where i can conferencing
with someone
and not having to worry about oh how do
i address the elephant in the room right
the odds might be already against you
before you even show your ideas
but i think now on zoom we can just
start with the ideas we can just start
with the deck
right i don't necessarily have to feel
and take a temperature pull of like oh
how do people
in the zoom call for my wheelchair
because when i show up like this
those questions kind of get erased
temporarily you know i mean i'll see you
know kind of what
if if their attitude translates to in
person when we do meet you know but
for now you know zoom calls i think has
been a great tool
of you know this equalizer in a way
certainly starting out in my audio
post-production career it was always
like
that elephant in the room i'm sitting in
a wheelchair and
it was only by having years and years of
experience and building a reputation
that preceded me
that i felt like i could really relax
about that when i first became a member
of the academy
i came down to los angeles and i went up
talking to um
the head of membership and i was asking
about disability and
percentages and stuff and she told me
you know jim
people are not willing to identify
because of the stigma of disability
the fact of the matter is in an ideal
world if everybody
revealed or identified
people in our industry would realize
that we're everywhere really
you know you can see me and jenny and
caitlin and yeah you can tell that
you know we have some body jazz going on
but there's so many different people
who are right with you that have to
hide their disabilities
i totally agree jim um i think when
jenny and i first connected many years
ago
we first became bonded because we have
the same disability
we have spinal muscular atrophy and i
thought wow
how cool is it that i'm seeing someone
else that is representing me and finding
the same
you know battle um i will you know just
challenge people
and think about it it's kind of like
people wearing glasses right having that
one tiny bit just makes a world of
difference
our chairs make that world different of
difference for us
for some other people it might be closed
captioning right
maybe they are hard of hearing at
certain times right and that's helpful
and having image descriptions that's
also helpful for other people
it's so common and yet it's something
that we're
still not sharing widely because it
carries the stigma
right i you know i challenge you do you
know anyone
who doesn't have anything
yeah yeah it's nice to see you know
that people are starting to be more open
and interested in the whole inclusion
discussions um do you think that the
industry could do more than what it's
doing
currently absolutely so i was bitten
you know by the visual effects bug at a
very young age
most you know like most vfx people i was
bitten by star wars and i was
absolutely blown away at all the visuals
i was seeing and i even remember you
know from many decades ago when i was a
nine-year-old
i was looking up visual effects you know
in these books
and i couldn't find any practitioners
who were women
so one of the questions i carry with me
for a long time was well
i hope they're going to be okay having a
woman working this field because this is
what i want to spend my life doing
and seeing the data now in 2020
i think that is still a legitimate
question right um there are still no
data no official data coming out but i
did a quick
data gathering on linkedin and
the the stats are not great um the stats
i found
um is basically zero point
zero zero one percent yeah visual fact
supervisors that are a woman
so we are still a couple digits of
becoming
a whole number and if anyone else wants
to
challenge me on those stats i welcome
them too
right because i would like to know other
you know a woman supervisors as well
i i think you even beat the female
directors i think that's even worse than
the numbers
yeah that's impossible i didn't think
that was possible but i think you did it
i started something called the gold test
which is similar to the
batch tell test that is the test about
if if there's two
females in a movie and they talk to each
other
about something other than a man and
most films don't pass that
simple test so i thought i would start
one called the gold test
is there a character with a disability
in this fictional story
that is three-dimensional and not
defined
by their disability to my surprise
uh there wasn't anybody
there wasn't anybody in the film
whatsoever in these fictitious worlds
that we're seeing so my thought is if
you don't
exist in our worlds of fiction how do
you exist in real life
when you're going out for that job how
does that employer know to hire you if
they haven't
even seen you in works of fiction we if
we look at
stereotypes that we hold and we all hold
stereotypes
about people and if we look at
what the stereotype is of people with
disabilities
it's not really good that you know that
we're and but
it is that it is really our industry's
responsibility
to not only hire people behind the
scenes
or in front of the camera but to produce
media embracing that
um we are members of society who are
vibrant and and add so much
and are incredibly capable you know
myself
jenny and you know jim we spend so much
of our time talking about
what makes us diverse when if you think
about it what makes us diverse
we had no say in being born with these
disabilities right
an area that we did have in say in is
the area that we studied and we
practiced
but we're still not being brought to the
table for
the area that we spent many years
studying we're still being you know
brought to the table saying oh hey let's
talk about what makes you diverse
right and i think we need to have these
conversations to get over this hurdle
to eventually shift the focus on our
work
but i think this is the start of that
and i think with the climate
of all the other you know activism
that's going on right now we really need
to harness this energy and use it for
good
and say hey it's not okay that we're not
even one percent
you know please help us achieve parity
what do you think that the studios need
to do the start of that is just asking
questions
right asking thoughtful questions i had
a producer once
who hired me to visual effects on set
and
they said hey so this is going to be my
first time working with someone in a
wheelchair right this is a new realm for
me and i'm
open to learning can you tell me what i
can do to help
is there anything you need right how can
i be the best support for you to do your
job well
on set you you i've been something i've
been wanting to say
and i really love what you said you know
if i'm gonna hire somebody
i'm not disabled instead of like
being on the negative like well just
tell me what you won't be able to do
tell me how i can uh
is there anything i can do to help you
do the best
work that you can i don't think i said
that quite eloquently but
you get the point and it's just it's a
different attitude
none of us get to your door with
with being oversensitive and mad at
everybody
we've gotten to you with being able to
deal
with our disability and we are
comfortable with our disability
so it's like ask the question let's get
it let's just take
care of and that you know i can be the
biggest help you're going to have
let's talk about what advice you might
give to
[Music]
young people coming into the business
today i think there's kind of a
universal piece of advice
for just about any question and that is
to find your community
and that is to find your tribe there are
people like myself and plenty of other
people that have already been
doing this work there is a group that i
helped found
called forward doc and it is a group of
documentary filmmakers with disabilities
you know we have over 100 members now
and i would say that if you if you can't
live without it
then you got to go and do it you know i
always said to myself when i was you
know little wouldn't it be great if i
can find
a female asian american
woman who wants to go into visual
effects so i can figure out how she's
done it you know and i hope that
others can take you know the lessons
i've learned along the way
to say that it is possible that's the
beauty of visual effects
anything is possible um if they can
you know make the millennium falcon
possible
making ramps to make other studios
accessible
is also possible don't give up it's
wonderful that kids today don't have to
be the pioneers that maybe the three of
us
were the ground workers laid hopefully
we've laid some more
today thank you all this has been a
wonderful
opportunity to to chat so thank you guys
for joining us
in an era of celebrating
intersectionality
let's not exclude disability from the
conversation
with disabilities make up more than 20
percent of the world's population
and come from all backgrounds including
various ethnicities
genders races and sexualities
what we see in motion pictures
influences the way we interact with the
world around us
in paving the way for a new generation
of storytellers
let's create and promote stories from
all these intersecting backgrounds
by hiring talent with lived experiences
to tell these stories
for our last panel let's hear from
animator
director writer jorge gutierrez
and actors millicent simmons and
zac gotsagen who will speak about
hollywood's untapped talent
and unlimited potential
fresh voices hollywood's untucked talent
and unlimited potential
with animation director jorge gutierrez
and actors melissa simmons
and zac gotsagan hi everyone
i am jorge gutierrez i am the creator
with my wife sandra giwa
of a cartoon called i'm also the
director and the co-writer of a movie
called the book of life
and currently i'm writing and directing
a netflix
movie series called mayanda3 it's my
pleasure to welcome the very talented
millicent simmons the star of
wonderstruck
and the blockbuster at quiet place and
the forthcoming
a quiet place part two which looks so
good
hi my name is millicent simmons
and i'm an actress currently i'm sitting
in a room
with a fireplace and a tv mounted on the
wall
it's a bright cheery room i'm wearing a
black long sleeve turtleneck and my hair
is pulled back in a low bun
i'm wearing a ring i'm a caucasian 17
year old female who is profoundly deaf
thanks for joining us millie and lastly
another extremely talented
young performer zach gotsagen is an
award-winning actor and the star of the
2019 indie hit
the peanut butter falcon which is
amazing my
name is uh zachary gossage
and i am
the actor and um
you know like i'm uh fun and
um um um just
did to be with my friends and my family
cool uh thanks for joining us zach uh i
forgot to do my
visual description uh i am a 45 year old
uh lovably chubby mexican
man with a black mustache and a hat that
belonged to my grandfather
let's kick things off with the title of
this discussion hollywood's
untapped talent and unlimited potential
what would you like to say to our
beloved industry
and all these producers and studio heads
and directors
about people like us that are
a little different but we have so much
more to offer
the title of this panel is so true
we do have talent and we are proving it
time and time again and we have been
throughout history
people with disabilities are continuing
to shock the world
and to change people's perspectives and
open their minds to
diversity
we are breaking through all of these
boundaries and barriers
we are continuing to educate people that
we're changing so much there is no limit
to what we can do now
that's wonderful zach do you want to
chime in i would say um
i would say i'm um good and
um um excitement
and and this showed
our talent absolutely yeah i i have a
i'm on the autism spectrum you know it's
a thing that
early in my life brought me some some
difficulties but it's actually made me
a lot more uh i would say it's become my
superpower and it's really allowed me
to be really really sort of focused in
my job and really sort of uh
uh inquisitive about the process so
that thing that as a kid i was told was
going to be
a weakness has turned out to be my
strength uh
what do you look for when reading a
script for a new project
have you had to fight to play a role
intended for a non-disabled person
when i'm reading through a script what
i'm looking for is
i have to have that aha moment that
moment when
i feel goosebumps or i feel shocked
because there's a twist in the story or
even a moment where i feel
i resonate with a particular character i
need to have that i need to have that
connection
with the character in order to immerse
myself
in their world and it helps me develop
my own character
in my way now i have had to
compete against non-disabled people for
particular roles i have had to audition
and again when i'm looking for a role
i try to find something that might suit
me i'm a young
teenage girl 17
and there might be a great role out
there for me i'm not above calling
directors and producers
suggesting they have a deaf actress for
a particular role
i don't know why we can't make changes
in scripts and in stories it makes
things more interesting
on a side note in the movie a quiet
place john krasinski intended
for the character reagan to be played by
a deaf actress
and the producers didn't want to have a
deaf actress they thought a hearing
actress would be
acceptable he fought for that because he
wanted to have an authentic experience
and to be able to have an actress who
understood what it felt like to be deaf
and how a deaf person would interact
and this is the reason why it's
important to have people with
disabilities playing characters who have
disabilities
because it makes it feel more real and
authentic
well you know i i work in animation and
the medium and animation lends itself
to creating characters of all types
especially
characters with disabilities and i
really believe
uh it's a it's our responsibility you
know especially someone like me a
director or a writer
to acknowledge people with disabilities
and put them in
the stories and in these films because
that's the world we live in
and i also believe that uh through the
power of animation you know a lot of it
is for children so when you plant those
seeds
and you uh basically illuminate children
to see disabled people as normal people
and and you know one of the one of the
things that i find
a little intriguing is a lot of times
the disabled characters are perfect
but what i really like is when the
disabled characters
have flaws because that's humanity right
the flaws are what reflects
uh a real depth of a person because
everyone who's disabled isn't instantly
a saint
uh we're all we all have our goods and
our bads
so i think it's really really important
to showcase uh that depth and that
that that humanity how do you feel your
success in hollywood
has been received by the public and by
the the save of community
i feel like when people started taking
notice of me
and my career most people didn't know
that
i'm actually deaf in real life and
people are typically very surprised by
that and they say things like
oh my gosh i had no idea that you're
deaf you act really well
and you're good enough to be in the
movies
it's always shocking and i'm never sure
how i feel when i receive responses like
that
in some sense i'm excited that i've
convinced them through
my acting skills to believe my character
but in another sense i feel a little bit
disappointed
and that i expect people should know
better a deaf character
should be played by a deaf actor or deaf
actress
but it doesn't happen that way a lot of
people don't know that
and it's really tough for me
as far as the disability community goes
i feel that the success i've had
has helped them as well they're setting
their
goals higher and achieving those goals
and from time to time i have fans reach
out to me
and they thank me for instilling
confidence in them
they say when they see themselves
represented in hollywood on
the silver screen it's just saying that
we are smart enough we are talented we
are good enough to do it
we can be successful we can break
through the barriers that have been set
for us
and that's not just in hollywood but in
so many other
areas as well whether it's technology or
science or media
and it's so inspiring
i am going to say about um um
uh those people
does love me
and they do love
my movie i
got many of the uh
boards awesome uh well you know i'll
tell you guys uh
when i first was diagnosed with autism i
was 40 years old so i didn't know
uh until much later because my son has
autism
and my parents said well he's just like
you when you were a kid
and then as soon as i found out uh the
people
who represent me said you shouldn't tell
anybody uh
it's gonna it's gonna it might be
something that uh
makes people think you're difficult you
know all the all the cliches and all the
bad
stereotypes uh and so i decided no you
know i'm gonna i think my work speaks
for itself i think what i do speaks for
itself
i'm going to be super open about my
diagnosis and i want to be a really good
example for my son
when he grows up and what that has
turned into is
the autism community has embraced me and
i didn't even know
i was a part of such a loving uh
community
i am now adding characters with autism
uh
in my in my work and i'm definitely uh
you know in animation i i joke that 50
of the people
are on the autism spectrum but they just
they've never been tested
uh but anyways what stories would you
like to see told in the future
and by whom
i would love to see stories about deaf
icons
and other icons in the disability
community
we already know who they are and where
they are now
but we don't know what their backstory
is
we don't know what their life was like
and what challenges and obstacles they
may have faced
i would love to see those icons
who have so much knowledge and
experience and
the ability to tell a story and to let
us connect with them and to do the
disability community justice i would
really like to see that
i would also love to see stories from
all over the world
i would love to hear about people's
culture
and their language and their traditions
it's an opportunity for us to all
educate ourselves and to learn from
other people
i am gonna say the prometic
um um uh story and of course um
um comedy um drama as
super
hero with the just just
abilities superhero with disabilities
that that would be
that'd be incredible zach oh my god i
want to make a good movie
what does the future of representation
and inclusion
in hollywood hopefully look like to you
i'm gonna say about the um um clues in
closing this is about
everybody with just
just abilities they really want
have a really good
change i would love to see a lot more
opportunity for people like us
i'd like to see more movies that focus
on
not only having a character with a
disability
viewed as sympathetic or less than
and more emphasis on characters with
disabilities
having more hope and for the people
watching
these movies and shows to become
educated and to learn
and to actually listen
i would love to see more barriers broken
down
and i want to see more opportunities for
people in the community to reach their
dreams
i want to see diversity i want to see
varying languages
and backgrounds and everything on screen
i want every person to feel like they're
represented
on the big screen and for people to feel
that they could even write their own
stories and share them with the world
great uh you know my my dream in in
representation
would be so that disability characters
are
normal uh and and they're in you know
genre movies there's a western
and one of the characters is disabled
and no one makes a big deal of it it's
just normal
or a sci-fi movie with someone uh you
know one of the faster the furious
movies and someone's in a wheelchair
and it's normal because that's the real
world so that's what i
would love to see what advice would you
like to give
young people with disabilities who want
to break into
our beloved film industry
advice for anyone who wants to pursue
acting as a career
is to have confidence in yourself get
yourself out of your comfort zone
and truly believe that you can make it
because no one's going to do that for
you you're the only one who can do that
for yourself
i would encourage you to get involved in
acting classes whether it be in school
or in the community
maybe you could try broadway and see how
different that experience is with
the facial expressions and the acting
approaches read as many books as you can
watch as many videos as you can get your
hands on watch director's cuts
watch different movies that are out
there and see what it takes
you really have to do the work for
yourself you could write your own story
even
because writing your own story allows
you
to say what you want and to share your
own vision in your own career
and you can decide what people might
want to know about
you and that's what i think is truly
important
the the advice i love to give is no
one's born a director
you become a director and you grow into
these roles
through hard work but it it's you know
if i i always say if i can do it
anybody can do it uh i'm gonna say um
um follow your heart
follow your dreams and someday
they will go big wow
that's beautiful so with talent like you
two
i think the future is looking so bright
i want to thank
all our guests today a huge thank you to
the brother men foundation
whose generous grant made this program
possible
and finally thank you our audience
uh for joining us today if you enjoyed
this program please share it with all
your friends and family
it's posted on the academy's facebook
page and the academy's youtube channel
as well as on oscars.org where you can
find some fantastic additional content
under extras so check it out and let's
keep this conversation going
thank you everybody
thank you so much thank you everybody
thank you this program is made possible
in part by the ruderman family
foundation
which promotes authentic representation
in the entertainment industry
and full inclusion of people with
disabilities throughout all sectors of
society
additional support provided by the los
angeles county board of supervisors
through the los angeles county
department
of arts and culture special thanks
amanda grazian kate lemonaccio charles
mastro pietro
emily simmons esther tejano jack jason
madison heim genevision melissa ziegler
rachel zavorsky renee rettinger shelly
gotsagan
stephanie ziske and trish carland